First Night It was a beautiful night, the
kind of night that only feels possible when
we are young, dear reader.
The sky was full of stars, so bright
and endless that, as I looked at it,
I couldn't help but wonder how grumpy or
moody people could live under such a sky.
That's a very youthful thought too, dear reader,
so youthful.
But may God grant that such thoughts enter
your heart more often.
Speaking of grumpy and moody people, I can't
help but think about how I felt all
day.
From the moment I woke up a strange
sadness weighed on me.
I couldn't shake the feeling that I was
completely alone, that everyone was leaving me behind.
Of course, you might ask, who is this
everyone you're talking about?
After all, I had lived in Petersburg for
almost eight years and barely knew anyone.
But what did I need acquaintances for?
I already felt like I knew all of
Petersburg.
That's why, when everyone in Petersburg seemed to
pack their things and move to their summer
homes, it felt like they were all leaving
me.
The thought of being left behind scared me,
and for three whole days I wandered the
city feeling down, unsure of what to do
with myself.
Whether I walked along Nevsky Prospekt, visited the
gardens, or strolled by the river bank, I
didn't see a single familiar face.
Those people didn't know me, of course, but
I knew them.
I knew them so well that it felt
like I had studied their faces.
Their happiness made me happy, and their gloom
brought me down.
I even felt as though I had formed
a sort of bond with one old man
I saw every single day at the same
time on Fontanka.
He had a serious, thoughtful expression, and he
always mumbled to himself while waving his left
hand.
In his right hand he carried a long,
knobby stick with a gold handle.
He even seemed to notice me and care
about me in his own way.
If I wasn't at my usual spot on
Fontanka, I was sure he felt disappointed.
Over time we almost started nodding to each
other in greeting, especially when we were both
in good spirits.
Just the other day, after missing each other
for two days, we nearly tipped our hats
as we passed, but we caught ourselves just
in time and simply exchanged curious glances.
I know the buildings in Petersburg too.
As I walk down the streets, it feels
like the buildings lean forward, peeking out their
windows to greet me.
Some of them seem to say, Good morning.
How are you?
I'm doing well, thank you, and I'll be
getting a new floor added in May.
Others might say, I'm being repainted tomorrow, or
I narrowly escaped a fire and was so
frightened.
I even have favorites among the buildings.
Some of them feel like old friends.
One building plans to undergo some renovations by
the architect this summer, and I'll make a
point of visiting daily to ensure the work
goes well.
Heaven forbid anything goes wrong.
But I'll never forget what happened with a
small, charming house that used to be a
lovely shade of pink.
It was such a delightful little brick house.
It stood proudly among its plain neighbors, and
seeing it always lifted my spirits.
Then one day last week I passed by,
and it seemed to cry out to me,
They're painting me yellow!
I was horrified.
Those barbarians!
They didn't spare a single detail, not the
columns, not the cornices.
My poor little friend was as yellow as
a canary.
It made me feel sick.
Even now I can't bring myself to visit
that house, now ruined by its awful new
color.
So now you understand, dear reader, how I
feel connected to all of Petersburg.
I already mentioned that I had been feeling
uneasy for three whole days before I finally
realized what was bothering me.
I felt restless on the streets.
This person was gone.
That one was gone.
And what had happened to the other?
Even at home I didn't feel like myself.
For two nights I racked my brain trying
to figure out what was wrong in my
little corner.
Why was it so uncomfortable all of a
sudden?
In my confusion I carefully inspected the dingy
green walls, the ceiling covered in cobwebs that
Matrona had allowed to flourish, and all my
furniture.
I checked every chair, wondering if the issue
was with them, because if even one chair
isn't in the same spot as the day
before, I feel unsettled.
I even studied the window, but none of
it helped.
Nothing felt better.
I thought about calling Matrona to talk about
the cobwebs and her general carelessness, but when
I finally did, she just stared at me
in silence, clearly baffled, and left without saying
a word.
The cobwebs, of course, are still hanging there,
undisturbed.
It wasn't until this morning that I finally
figured it out.
Ah, everyone is leaving for their summer homes.
Excuse the simplicity of my words, but I'm
not in the mood for fancy language right
now.
Everything and everyone in Petersburg had either left
or was preparing to leave for the holidays.
Every respectable-looking gentleman I saw taking a
cab seemed to transform in my mind into
a devoted head of the household on his
way to join his family at a summer
villa.
Every passerby seemed to carry an air of
transition, as if to say to the world,
I'm only here for a little while longer,
and soon I'll be off to the summer
villa.
If a window opened and a pair of
delicate snow-white fingers tapped on the glass,
before a pretty young woman leaned out to
call to a flower-seller, I immediately imagined
the flowers weren't for her stuffy apartment, but
for the countryside, where she would soon be
moving.
I became so caught up in my new
obsession that I began to feel I could
tell, just by looking at people, which summer
villa they were heading to.
Those going to Kameny or Aptokarsky Islands or
the Peterhof Road stood out with their polished
manners, stylish summer outfits, and elegant carriages.
Those bound for Pargolovo or more distant places
had a calm and dignified air.
Meanwhile, people heading to Krestovsky Island were unmistakable
with their carefree, lively energy.
If I happened to see a long line
of carts carrying heaps of furniture—tables, chairs, sofas,
and all sorts of household items—often with an
old cook perched on top of it all,
fiercely guarding her employer's belongings, or boats loaded
with goods slowly gliding along the Neva or
Fontanka on their way to the Black River
or the Islands, it felt as though these
scenes were everywhere.
In my mind I multiplied these wagons and
boats tenfold, a hundredfold.
It seemed like the whole city was moving
in caravans to summer villas.
It felt as if Petersburg was on the
verge of becoming a ghost town.
I started to feel embarrassed, frustrated, and deeply
sad that I had no place to go
for the holidays and no reason to leave
the city.
I wanted to join every wagon, ride off
with every dignified gentleman in a cab, but
no one, not a single person, invited me.
It was as if they had all forgotten
about me entirely, as if I didn't belong
to their world at all.
I went on long walks, often so lost
in thought that I forgot where I was
until I suddenly found myself at the city
gates.
As soon as I realized where I was,
I felt a wave of relief.
I crossed the boundary and walked through fields
and meadows.
I didn't feel tired at all, only as
though a heavy weight had been lifted from
my heart.
Everyone I passed looked at me with such
kind expressions that it felt like they were
silently greeting me.
They all seemed so cheerful, as if something
wonderful had just happened, and nearly all of
them were smoking cigars.
Their happiness made me feel a joy I
hadn't known before.
It felt almost as if I had been
transported to Italy.
So powerful was the effect of nature on
someone like me, a half-sick city dweller,
suffocating within the walls of the town.
There is something incredibly moving about the nature
around Petersburg.
Especially in early spring, when it seems to
use every ounce of strength it has.
It bursts into bloom, covers itself in green
leaves, and sprinkles itself with flowers, as if
putting on its finest attire.
It reminds me of a delicate, sickly girl,
the kind you might look at with pity
or tenderness, or perhaps not notice at all.
Then, out of nowhere, she becomes breathtakingly beautiful,
almost as if by accident.
Her sad, thoughtful eyes suddenly glow with fire,
her pale cheeks flush with color, her features
soften, and her face fills with passion and
life.
Her smile becomes radiant, her laughter sparkles, and
her beauty overwhelms you.
It's impossible not to wonder what caused this
transformation.
What gave her such vitality, such life?
What brought that glow to her face and
made her movements so full of grace?
But then the moment vanishes.
The next day you might see her again,
but she's back to the way she was
before, quiet, pale, and distant, with a look
of sorrow in her eyes.
You can even sense regret or anguish in
her expression, as if she's mourning the brief,
fleeting moment of beauty she allowed herself.
And you feel sad too, heartbroken that her
beauty disappeared so quickly, that it came and
went like a passing dream.
You grieve because it felt like you didn't
even have enough time to fully appreciate it,
to truly love her.
And yet, as beautiful as that day was,
the night that followed was even better.
Here's what happened.
I returned to the city very late, and
it was already ten o'clock by the
time I was heading back to my lodging.
My path took me along the canal embankment,
a place where, at that hour, you never
see a single person.
To be fair, I live in a very
isolated part of the city.
I walked along, humming a song.
When I'm happy, I always hum to myself,
like anyone who's joyful but has no one
to share that happiness with.
Then, out of nowhere, something completely unexpected happened.
Leaning against the canal railing stood a woman,
her elbows resting on the rail, as she
stared intently at the murky water below.
She wore a lovely yellow hat and a
stylish black shawl.
She's young, and I bet she has dark
hair, I thought.
She didn't seem to notice the sound of
my footsteps or react in any way as
I walked past her, my heart pounding loudly
in my chest.
How odd, I thought.
She must be lost in her thoughts.
Then, suddenly, I stopped in my tracks, frozen.
I heard a soft, muffled sob.
Yes, there was no mistaking it.
The woman was crying.
A moment later, the quiet sobs became louder,
one after another.
My heart sank.
Though I was usually nervous around women, this
was different.
It felt like an extraordinary moment.
I turned back, took a step toward her,
and was just about to say, Miss, but
stopped myself, realizing how cliché it sounded, like
something out of every Russian novel I'd ever
read.
That thought alone made me hesitate.
As I fumbled for the right words, she
seemed to collect herself.
She turned her head slightly, noticed me, started,
and quickly looked down.
Without a word, she moved past me and
began walking along the embankment.
Instinctively, I followed her.
She must have realized it because she veered
off the embankment, crossed the street, and continued
along the pavement.
I didn't dare cross after her, my heart
beating wildly like a trapped bird.
Then fate seemed to step in and offer
me a chance.
On the same side of the pavement where
she was walking, a man suddenly appeared.
He was wearing evening clothes and looked to
be middle-aged, though his unsteady gait and
the way he leaned against the wall made
him seem less than dignified.
The woman quickened her pace, walking with the
nervous urgency you see in women who want
to avoid being approached at night.
It seemed likely the staggering man wouldn't follow
her, except, unfortunately, he did.
Without any warning, the man sprang forward and
began chasing her at full speed.
She ran like the wind, but he was
catching up, getting closer and closer.
She let out a sharp scream, and in
that instant I silently thanked the sturdy walking
stick I happened to be carrying in my
right hand.
In a heartbeat I crossed the street, and
in another the drunken man seemed to understand
the situation.
He noticed my stick, recognized the unspoken thread
it carried, and immediately backed off without saying
a word.
Only when we were far down the road
did I hear him muttering curses in our
direction, but his voice was too faint to
make out.
Take my arm, I said to the woman.
He won't bother us any more.
She hesitated for only a moment before linking
her trembling arm with mine.
She was still shaking, overwhelmed by fear and
excitement.
Oh, drunken stranger, how I silently thanked you
in that moment!
I glanced at her out of the corner
of my eye and saw that she was
even more beautiful than I had guessed, dark
-haired, just as I'd imagined.
Her long, dark lashes were still wet with
tears, though I couldn't tell if they were
from the terror she had just experienced or
from whatever had made her cry earlier.
Yet a faint smile was beginning to form
on her lips.
She, too, stole a quick glance at me,
her cheeks turning a soft pink before she
lowered her gaze again.
You see, I said gently, why did you
push me away earlier?
If I'd been there, this never would have
happened.
But I didn't know you, she replied quietly.
I thought you might have been like him.
And now?
Do you think you know me better?
Maybe a little, she said, still looking down.
But why are you shaking?
Oh, you've guessed it right away, I replied,
thrilled that this girl was so clever.
Intelligence always goes so well with beauty.
Yes, from the very first look you figured
me out completely.
You're right, I'm shy around women.
I get nervous just like you did a
moment ago when that man scared you.
To be honest, I'm a little nervous now.
This feels like a dream.
And I never imagined, even in my wildest
dreams, that I'd ever have a real conversation
with a woman.
What?
Really?
Yes, really.
If my arm is trembling, it's because it
has never been held by a small, lovely
hand like yours before.
I've never had much to do with women.
You see, I'm always alone.
I don't even know how to talk to
them properly.
In fact, I'm not sure if I've already
said something foolish to you.
Be honest with me.
Please tell me if I have.
I promise I won't be offended.
No, no, not at all.
Quite the opposite.
And if you really want me to be
honest, I'll tell you that women actually like
that kind of nervousness.
And to be even more honest, I like
it too.
I won't send you away until I've made
it home safely.
You're going to make me lose all my
shyness, I said, almost breathless with happiness.
And once that happens, all my chances will
be gone.
Chances?
What chances?
That's not a very nice thing to say.
I'm sorry it just slipped out, but how
can anyone not want to make a good
impression at a moment like this?
You mean to be liked, right?
Yes, exactly.
But please be kind to me.
Think about who I am.
I'm twenty-six years old, and I've never
known anyone like you.
How can I possibly say the right things
or be smooth and confident?
Maybe you'll understand better if I just tell
you everything.
I don't know how to keep quiet when
my heart is speaking, but never mind all
that.
Believe me, I've never been with a woman,
not even once.
No friendships, no relationships, nothing.
Every day I just dream about finally meeting
someone.
Oh, if only you knew how many times
I've fallen in love in my dreams.
Really?
With who?
With no one in particular, with an ideal,
with a person I imagine in my dreams.
I make up entire stories in my head.
You don't know me at all.
Of course, I've met a few women before,
but what kind of women were they?
They were all landladies, people like that, but
I'm sure you'll laugh if I tell you
this.
I've even thought about speaking to some elegant
woman on the street a few times.
Of course, only if she was alone.
I imagined myself approaching her timidly and respectfully,
explaining how lonely I am, begging her not
to turn me away.
I'd tell her that I don't have any
opportunities to meet women, and that it's almost
a moral duty for her not to reject
such a desperate request.
I'd ask her to say just a few
kind words to me, as if she were
my sister.
I wouldn't ask for much, just two or
three words of sympathy.
She could laugh at me if she wanted
to, but I'd hope she wouldn't reject me
outright.
Even if we never saw each other again,
just those few words would mean so much.
But you're laughing now, and that's exactly why
I'm telling you all this.
Don't be upset.
I'm only laughing at how you're your own
worst enemy.
If you had tried, you might have succeeded,
even if it had been on the street.
Simplicity is best.
No kind-hearted woman, unless she were either
foolish or in a bad mood at the
time, could turn you away without those two
little words you're so shy to ask for.
But wait, what am I saying?
Of course, she might think you're crazy.
I was judging by myself.
I know quite a bit about other people's
lives.
Oh, thank you, I exclaimed.
You don't know what you've just done for
me?
I'm glad, I'm so glad.
But tell me, how did you know I
was the kind of woman who—well, someone you'd
think worthy—of your attention and friendship?
Not just a landlady, as you say?
What made you decide to approach me?
What made me?
Well, you were alone.
That man was being far too rude.
And it was night-time.
You have to admit, it felt like my
duty.
No, no, I mean before, when you were
on the other side of the canal.
You know you were planning to come up
to me.
The other side?
Honestly, I don't know how to answer.
I'm afraid to say.
Do you know I've been happy today?
I walked around singing.
I went out into the countryside.
I've never felt moments like that before.
You—perhaps I imagined it.
Forgive me for saying this, but I thought
you were crying, and I couldn't bear it.
It hurt my heart.
Surely it's okay that I was concerned for
you.
Surely there's no harm in feeling a kind
of brotherly compassion for someone?
I'm sorry, I said compassion.
But really, is it wrong for me to
have felt such a strong urge to approach
you?
Stop, that's enough.
Don't say any more, she said, looking down
and pressing my hand.
It's my fault for bringing it up.
But I'm glad I wasn't wrong about you.
And now, here I am at home.
I must turn down this street.
It's just a few steps from here.
Goodbye, and thank you.
Surely, surely you don't mean that we'll never
see each other again?
This can't be the end, can it?
You see, she said, laughing.
At first, you only wanted two words.
And now—well, I won't say anything.
Maybe we'll meet again.
I'll come here tomorrow, I said.
Oh, forgive me.
I'm already making demands.
Yes, you're not very patient.
You're almost insisting.
Listen, please, listen, I interrupted her.
Forgive me for saying this, but I have
to tell you something else.
I can't stop myself from coming back here
tomorrow.
I'm a dreamer.
My real life is so empty that moments
like this are rare treasures for me.
I hold on to them and relive them
in my dreams.
I'll be dreaming of you all night, all
week, maybe all year.
I'll definitely come back here tomorrow, to this
very spot, at the same time.
And I'll feel happy just remembering today.
This place is already special to me.
I have two or three places like this
in Petersburg.
Once I even cried over memories in one
of those places.
Just like you.
Who knows, maybe ten minutes ago you were
crying over a memory, too.
But forgive me.
I've let myself ramble again.
Perhaps you've been especially happy here once before.
Very good, said the girl.
Perhaps I will come here tomorrow, too, at
ten o'clock.
I see that I can't forbid you.
The fact is, I have to be here.
Don't imagine that I'm making an appointment with
you.
I tell you beforehand that I have to
be here on my own account.
But— Well, I tell you straight out, I
don't mind if you do come.
To begin with, something unpleasant might happen as
it did today, but never mind that.
In short, I should simply like to see
you.
To say two words to you.
Only mind you must not think the worse
of me now.
Don't think I make appointments so lightly.
I shouldn't make it except that.
But let that be my secret, only a
compact beforehand.
A compact?
Speak, tell me, tell me all beforehand.
I agree to anything.
I am ready for anything, I cry delighted.
I answer for myself.
I will be obedient, respectful.
You know me.
It's just because I do know you that
I ask you to come tomorrow, said the
girl, laughing.
I know you perfectly.
But mind you will come on the condition
in the first place.
Only be good, do what I ask.
You see, I speak frankly.
You won't fall in love with me.
That's impossible, I assure you.
I am ready for friendship.
Here's my hand.
But you mustn't fall in love with me,
I beg you.
I swear, I cried, gripping her hand.
Hush, don't swear.
I know you are ready to flare up
like gunpowder.
Don't think ill of me for saying so.
If only you knew, I too have no
one to whom I can say a word,
whose advice I can ask.
Of course, one does not look for an
advisor in the street, but you are an
exception.
I know you as though we had been
friends for twenty years.
You won't deceive me, will you?
You will see.
The only thing is, I don't know how
I am going to survive the next twenty
-four hours.
Sleep soundly, good night, and remember that I
have trusted you already.
But you exclaimed so nicely just now, surely
one can't be held responsible for every feeling,
even for brotherly sympathy.
Do you know that was so nicely said,
that the idea struck me at once, that
I might confide in you?
For God's sake do, but about what?
What is it?
Wait till tomorrow.
Meanwhile, let that be a secret.
So much the better for you.
It will give it a faint flavor of
romance.
Perhaps I will tell you tomorrow, and perhaps
not.
I will talk to you a little more
beforehand.
We will get to know each other better.
Oh, yes, I will tell you all about
myself tomorrow.
But what has happened?
It is as though a miracle had befallen
me.
My God, where am I?
Come tell me, aren't you glad that you
were not angry and did not drive me
away at the first moment as any other
woman would have done?
In two minutes you have made me happy
forever.
Yes, happy.
Who knows, perhaps, you have reconciled me with
myself, solved my doubts.
Perhaps such moments come upon me.
But there I will tell you all about
it tomorrow.
You shall know everything, everything.
Very well, I consent.
You shall begin.
Agreed.
Goodbye till tomorrow.
Till tomorrow.
And we parted.
I walked about all night.
I could not make up my mind to
go home.
I was so happy.
Tomorrow.